[Music]
the differences in our genes come about
through a natural process called
mutation
mutation is extremely common
as a cell copies its dna before dividing
it makes occasional typos
most commonly a single base is
substituted for another
sometimes a base is deleted or an extra
base is added
the cell is able to repair most of these
typos
but each round of cell division
introduces a few changes that are not
repaired
when dna changes occur in cells that
will give rise to eggs or sperm they can
be passed down to offspring
each one of us has about 60 new
variations that were not present in our
parents
people commonly use the terms mutant and
mutation to describe something
undesirable or broken
but mutation is not always bad
most dna changes fall in the large areas
of the genome that sit between genes and
they usually have no effect
when variations occur in areas of the
genome that code for proteins they often
have consequences
these changes can affect the protein
product itself or they can affect when
where or how much protein is made
most of the time mutation generates
variations that are neither good nor bad
just different
while a mutation is defined as any
alteration in the dna sequence
biologists use the term single
nucleotide polymorphism or snip to refer
to a single base pair alteration that is
common in the population
specifically a polymorphism is any
genetic location at which at least two
different sequences are found with each
sequence present in at least one percent
of the population
note that the term polymorphism is
generally used to refer to a normal
variation or one that does not directly
cause disease
moreover the cutoff of at least one
percent prevalence for a variation to be
classified as a polymorphism is somewhat
arbitrary if the frequency is lower than
this the allele is typically regarded as
a mutation
snips are important as markers or
signposts for scientists to use when
they look at populations of organisms in
an attempt to find genetic changes that
predispose individuals to certain traits
including disease
on average snips are found every one
thousand to two thousand nucleotides in
the human genome and scientists
participating in the international
hapmap consortium have mapped millions
of these alterations
the dna in any cell can be altered
through environmental exposure to
certain chemicals ultraviolet radiation
other genetic insults or even errors
that occur during the process of
replication
sickle cell anemia is a disease caused
by a change in a single nucleotide and
it represents just one class of
mutations called point mutations
the alteration of a single nucleotide in
the gene for the beta chain of the
hemoglobin protein the oxygen carrying
protein that makes blood red is all it
takes to turn a normal hemoglobin gene
into a sickle cell hemoglobin gene
this single nucleotide change alters
only one amino acid in the protein chain
but the results are devastating
molecules of sickle cell hemoglobin
stick to one another forming rigid rods
these rods cause a person's red blood
cells to take on a deformed sickle-like
shape thus giving the disease its name
the rigid misshapen blood cells do not
carry oxygen well and they also tend to
clog capillaries causing an affected
person's blood supply to be cut off to
various tissues including the brain and
the heart
therefore when an afflicted individual
exerts himself or herself even slightly
he or she often experiences terrible
pain and he or she might even undergo
heart attack or stroke all because of a
single nucleotide mutation
mutations can also alter the way a gene
is read through either the insertion or
the deletion of a single base
in these so-called frame shift mutations
entire proteins are altered as a result
of the deletion or insertion
this occurs because nucleotides are read
by ribosomes in groups of three called
codons
thus if the number of bases removed or
inserted from a gene is not a multiple
of three the reading frame for the rest
of the protein is thrown off
changes in the dna sequence can also
occur at the level of the chromosome in
which large segments of chromosomes are
altered
in this case fragments of chromosomes
can be deleted duplicated inverted
translocated to different chromosomes or
otherwise rearranged resulting in
changes such as modification of gene
dosage the complete absence of genes or
the alteration of gene sequence
the type of variation that occurs when
entire areas of chromosomes are
duplicated or lost called copy number
variation cnv has especially important
implications for human disease and
evolution